and it went welcome to this video max
Kushner okay the new opponent let's see
what do we get Kings Indian by
transposition awesome modern defense
Kings Indian by transposition okay okay
so he closes the center immediately this
is usually a risky strategy against this
kind of setup Wow okay place the bangko
with the pawn on e5 okay map one is on
g4 admittedly this is also not the
greatest greatest position for it ever
but still okay um what happens here I
can try eight eggs can play this with 8x
be five probably assure them
okay let's let's see you think for a
moment yeah maybe just cancels and get
to get out of the out of the situation
here and and get some coordination what
to do I think let's prevent I know it's
not very urgent I think I probably need
this move so cakes i'll take with the
night i guess the bishop he is not doing
anything probably should go to d 2 i'm
sorry i mean the bishop should should go
into III so that night can go to the
tube this is what i try to save
unsuccessfully I can lend some support
to this
some of the easiest test right to take
on a six and goodnight b5 next I'm not
quite sure what he's doing I thought if
anything you should try for some play on
the King side but it does not seem to be
on this agenda at all okay 94 Jim it's a
complete complete the coordination here
you cannot go see for here anyway so try
to play against f5 here i wonder if i
should play rook in one next yeah he
wants to try to trade this okay if i go
here i'm a threatening a five winning
the night so he cannot go bishop chief
i'll immediately yes this is possible
quincy three
hmm
I can go back to a three actually and
then nights your form this is probably
good
okay and let me 22 ok so I cannot take
this here because our chief 54 k
how to go to see 6 cm
Wow p 5
I can also just take it huh it's not
nothing wrong with capturing
one minutes 29 25 maybe this is this
that too sick dangerous check all of a
sudden here check you have to go back
over the way and then Bishop d3 probably
hmm now i wanna know I have to be I have
to counter counter attack him probably
spoil this somehow membership each fall
on the Sun
oh now that I didn't see wow wow it was
for them difficult to lose the game but
I managed okay white resins ji was a
plus million position of course around
here yeah so I have turned probably
maybe 20 25 was too was was too close to
him too fancy I I mean I just wanted to
trade stuff the problem was that I
didn't see Bishop edge for coming I just
saw the check I saw I saw that he has to
check here which is which is check and
just nothing but this is all of a sudden
dangerous Queenie evaders right I guess
and now yeah I didn't see create who I
just didn't see the move or Quincy too
for that matter now create a 2 is the
problem and this is the real ischium
this and now how can i still defend this
look to you one not that I understand
why this defense this is losers of
course but i want to set defend I don't
understand it I looked it you are okay
wow so I have to have to play this is
the only move forward T to that stuff no
I didn't seek we need to now
yeah the final mistake is costing 11
mistaken yeah Queen d5 was the first
mistake to allow anything in the first
place but that second one costs the game
yeah the whole game was not much to talk
about to be honest I probably get get
some people posting bad comments again
about this but b5 is this is e 5c 5 and
d5 combined it's probably more or less
losing for black n why does the pawn up
has more space and blackheads no counter
play the whole game was basically
one-way street I'm blocking the Queen
side now consolidating the King side and
yeah slowly making making the progress
down 90 over to c6 so I'm pretty
straightforward Kim computer agrees with
everything it's plus 3 I just have to
have to avoid 25 here just play a normal
book like this now they've also also
applied this to quickly went on long did
that take six seconds spoon now I should
have thought for a moment down being
down 40 seconds it's I can still take a
couple of seconds longer and see ya then
I should just keep everything this also
keeps a five so no move Black has no
move here engine gives this and yeah
this is a very simple win huh okay then
he had 11 tricky and the game and and
got it got it in okay thanks for
watching